[Music]
jacob's going to start this hour off in
fargo north dakota hi jacob welcome to
the ramsey show
hello mr ramsay it's a pleasure to meet
you how are you doing better than i
deserve sir how can i help great so i'm
a 20 year old college student and i
recently finished my sophomore year of
college and i'm currently studying to
become a nurse i have roughly two years
left in my program and i'll be able to
graduate debt free in 2024. good for you
in addition to that yeah thank you in
addition to that i currently work as a
cna at a large hospital in the fargo
area and i was recently approached by my
my manager who came up with an offer for
me and she presented an offer where i
would be able to work at this hospital
for three years after graduation
in addition to that i will receive a
thirty thousand dollar sign on bonus um
given that i'm only halfway through this
program i'm a little hesitant at the
moment to take this offer but i'm
curious if this is something i should
entertain
so the only advantage to you
is 30 000 bucks
correct and i've had a really strong
working relationship with this hospital
and i do enjoy working at this hospital
okay have you looked at options in your
area for other hospitals and what the
pay would be
i have a little bit um currently this
hospital pays about two dollars less an
hour than other hospitals um but it's a
very good starting wage for nurses in
this area um in this part of the country
so it's
i consider it to be competitive
okay
well i i'm kind of with you
number one let's just establish nursing
incredible career path
and as long as i've been doing this show
for 30 years there's been a shortage of
nurses
correct so you've always been able to
land a job
you know and lots of different kinds of
jobs actually within the nursing field
and so a lot of flexibility always a
need for you
that kind of thing so if that's kind of
our baseline
then off of that
i don't think i'm tying up
uh
myself
um you don't need the money
you've got you've got a way to work your
way through school with no debt you told
us that way to go good job
and um and so the money's just kind of
gravy on the biscuit it'd be nice but
you know it's not like
it's not like oh i cannot have to borrow
student loans if i do this uh i might
think about it then
but in this case you got your way mapped
out to go all the way through and then
you're a free agent upon graduation
i'll bet you could get more than 30 000
at that point
true yeah and that's that's the part
that i'm struggling with is it's really
hard to predict what would be out there
in two years if we're at a peak now if
this is a good time to take an offer but
i i i think i think there'll be a
you know again i'm going to say i'm
going to establish the fact in my mind
anyway anecdotally i don't have research
to back it up but
that there's pretty much always a
shortage of nurses
and so that means that you will be able
to land something
and probably something with a signing
bonus i wouldn't doubt it a bit
so um i kind of think that offer or
better might be on the table at
graduation
i might be wrong we're gambling what's
the harm in waiting until graduation
thirty thousand bucks if they won't if
they don't have any more you know yeah
you miss out on that if if we're wrong
right if it's off the table um but the
way i answer questions on this show is
if i woke up in your shoes what would i
do
i'm uh
i'm gonna bet that there's uh gonna be
as good a deal or better on uh
on the table and i'm gonna say thanks
uh let's talk as i get a little bit
closer to graduation
okay that's the advice i needed to hear
so thank you so much thank you brother
appreciate you calling
man i got to tell you george these uh
this is the sharpest bunch of 20 year
olds i've run in they're everywhere of
course they call i'll call this show and
you know my gosh i mean his question
written out but yeah you know but still
it's
gives me hope yeah it's pretty
impressive people actually want to work
out there when i was 20 nobody's
offering me a signing bonus i'm just
saying okay i'm just just saying all
right